We've come a long way from Superfriends, haven't
we?
What once was a joke of a movie from Entourage
has now become a multimillion dollar, worldwide
hit.
“The suit will not look like that on film.
Tom Cruise is like 5’4 and on screen he
looks like Yao Ming.”
Yes, Aquaman is here, and it’s filled with
plenty of small nods to the wider world beyond
just DC Comics.
Here are some of the small details in Aquaman
you may have missed.
And if you haven't seen the movie yet, stick
some seaweed over your eyes, you dummy.
There are spoilers in these waters!
When Atlanna and Tom - Aquaman's Aquamom and
Aquadad - meet for the first time, we got
a glimpse into some of the ways Tom liked
to spend his free time.
You know, when he's not rescuing washed up
merwomen from the rocks down near the edge
of his lighthouse.
If any moviegoers watched a lot of serial
children's TV in the 1960s, they might've
noticed that Tom had an episode of Stingray
playing on his television.
That is, right before Atlanna threw her trident
through it once she regained consciousness.
Stingray, for those who aren't familiar, concerned
a heroic submarine crew that discovers civilizations
secretly living on the ocean's floor, and
the high-adventure hijinks that ensue as a
result of that discovery.
All things considered, it's a pretty fitting
television choice for Tom, if maybe a little
on the nose.
Eagle eyed fans might've spotted a book featuring
the works of H.P.
Lovecraft on one of Tom's tables.
While Lovecraft is known for lots of weird
contributions to horror and pop culture, his
best known invention is probably Cthulhu,
an ancient type of cosmic sea-monster who
has a whole bunch of tentacles on his octopus-face.
The various civilizations we see throughout
Aquaman - as well as the secret ocean in the
center of the world and particularly the sea-monster
who guards Atlan's trident - all seem to be
at least partially inspired by Cthulhu and
the rest of Lovecraft's creepy writing.
While Aquaman director James Wan may not necessarily
be a household name just yet, fans of horror
movies are extremely familiar with his work.
Wan became well known for his work on the
Conjuring movies, which feature a pair of
paranormal investigators who, well, go and
investigate the paranormal.
And one of those creepy supernatural things
is the Annabelle doll, which viewers could
spot sitting near Mera's ship shortly after
she brings Arthur down to the ocean to begin
their adventure.
And that's not the only reference back to
the Conjuring series of movies.
Patrick Wilson, who played King Orm, has appeared
in both Conjuring films as Ed Warren, who's
based on a real-life ghost-chaser from which
the movie franchise takes its inspiration.
And, while we're on the subject of Patrick
Wilson, this isn't even the first time he's
appeared in a Warner Bros. superhero movie.
Back in 2009, he appeared as Nite Owl in Zack
Snyder's Watchmen adaptation.
Randall Park made a couple of memorable appearances
on Aquaman's fictional TV network GBS as Doctor
Stephen Shin.
Even for Aquaman, Shin is pretty obscure compared
with the rest of the character's comics history.
Shin debuted in 2011's DC Comics reboot as
an ally of Arthurs.
But Shin comes into conflict with Arthur when
the hero refuses to reveal the secret location
of Atlantis.
Based on the film's single post-credits scene
- where Shin and Black Manta seem to team
up - chances seem good that Shin's role will
be expanded by quite a bit in the eventual
sequel.